investigators unfounded allegations of
Fraud and vote tampering cloud of the
2020 election this year there's one big
threat for federal law enforcement 8
news now investigator David charns here
now with that part of our coverage
tonight David yeah Denise as we have
reported since even before the last
election there were some people who
claimed the 2020 election was stolen
even before people were voting tonight
the head of the FBI's Las Vegas office
says misinformation and voter
intimidation are the biggest threats to
democracy and next week's election the
undermining of the election Integrity
itself is by far the biggest threat FBI
special agent in charge Spencer Evans
says the biggest threat to next week's
election is misinformation in lies so
the FBI is concerned because election
Integrity is at the center of what it
means to be an American and to be able
to have free and open and fair elections
the FBI and its local in-state
counterparts are looking at several
potential threats to under mind the
election they include voter intimidation
threats toward election workers outside
interference from a foreign power and
misinformation to suppress the vote
there's no credible information any of
those actions are underway right now to
the extent that they are that they can
be made safe I am confident that the FBI
and its Partners have done everything
possible to make fair and open elections
a reality for all in the violence
investigators reported in August an
independent audit of the Clark County
Election Department found no issues
regarding how Nevada's largest county
processes mail-in ballots from their
creation to their tabulations Evans did
not comment on specifics about any
threat Nationwide or here in Nevada but
says the FBI is watching in these days
to come and they will be watching after
election day even though this
environment is hypercharged politically
we need to make sure the FBI is
committed to ensuring that the rule of
law is followed and that we follow the
facts wherever they lead us now since
2020 the Department of Justice has
worked harder to keep election and poll
workers safe the FBI asking you to
report any potential election related
crimes to them it's really simple to do
all you have to do is call 800 call FBI
I'm David charns 8 news now Denise